moi je suis contre l'interdiction pour
je suis pour l'interdiction du voile
dans l'espace public je l'ai dit je l'ai
dit de la manière la plus claire je
pense que le voile est
un uniforme imposé par les islamistes je
pense que les grandes parties des jeunes
femmes qui le mettent ne peuvent pas
faire autrement réalité même si elle
n'ose pas le dire puisque celle qui ne
le mettent pas en revanche témoigne du
fait qu'elles sont isolées du fait que
elles sont insultées du fait que elles
sont mises de côté et accusés d'être
impur c'est ça je crois cette situation
n'est pas admissible dans notre pays
donc il faut
libérer l'ensemble de ces femmes il faut
faire reculer les islamistes et pour
cela je le crois il faut interdire le
voile dans l'espace public Emmanuel
Macron que ferez-vous si vous êtes réélu
concernant le port du voile dans
l'espace public restez-vous au statu quo
présent ou changerez-vous la loi
d'abord je vous écoutais vous faites
avec beaucoup de clarté
démonstration mais ce qui est inquiétant
dans votre démonstration c'est le chemin
qu'elle emprunte
d'une question sur le voile vous êtes
passé au terrorisme pour revenir à
l'islamisme et pour aller aux étrangers
et vous créez un système d'équivalence
par votre cheminement qui confondent
tous les problèmes et qui les entretient
la question du voile c'est la question
d'une religion un signe extérieur
religieux
la question du foulard plus exactement
d'ailleurs moi je suis pour la loi de
1905 c'est notre République la
République et laïque la laïcité ça n'est
pas à combattre une religion et donc
avec moi il n'y aura pas l'interdiction
ni du foulard ni de la kippa ni de
quelques signes religieux dans l'espace
public parce que le principe d'égalité
fait que si vous rentrez dans cette
logique Madame Le Pen vous interdirez
tous les signes religieux dans l'espace
public et pas simplement le foulard vous
n'avez pas lu ma loi non mais j'ai lu la
Constitution française vous m'excuserez
de cela et elle est
les lois vous prendrez même si vous
étiez élu ce que je ne souhaite pas
évidemment elle devra respecter une
constitution bon et donc notre
Constitution nos textes fondamentaux
c'est cela c'est la laïcité la laïcité
c'est un principe de liberté et donc à
l'école il n'y a pas de voile parce
qu'on forme des consciences il y a aucun
signe religieux d'ailleurs c'est pas que
le foulard tous les signes religieux
sont proscrits puisqu'on forme
des consciences des citoyens en devenir
dans les services publics il y a une
neutralité des services publics à l'état
absolue par contre dans la cité
vous allez créer la guerre civile si
vous faites ça je vous le dis en toute
sincérité parce que ça veut dire que
vous vous êtes sacrées
pas de se soumettre à la loi ce que vous
dites et très grave je vous le dis
vraiment avec vous non
vous êtes en train de dire anticipation
vous êtes en train de personnes qui
refuseraient d'appliquer la loi je suis
en train de vous dire que la France
patrie des Lumières de l'universel
serait le premier pays au monde à
interdire les signes religieux dans
l'espace public le premier pays au monde
c'est ça ce que vous proposez Sana aucun
sens ça n'est pas le respect de nos
valeurs ce sera même un faisable combien
de policiers le premier pays au monde à
mettre en place beaucoup de loi vous
savez de liberté de tolérance là vous
proposer une loi d'interdiction
c'est une loi de rejet parce que vous
confondez deux choses vous avez oublié
sur le voile il y a quelques années
justement je suis fidèle à tout ce que
j'ai toujours voulu dire défendu
d'ailleurs j'aurais passé des lois si je
pensais le contraire mais Madame Le Pen
c'est pas la France de l'universalisme
parce que vous proposez combien de
policiers de gendarmes iront courir
après un voile une qui passe une
religieuse donc ceux qui ont couru après
les masques vous savez ce qu'ils avaient
vraiment que c'était temporaire et les
gens ont été rigoureux
ce n'est pas sérieux donc ça c'est mon
premier point sur le sur le foulard
laïcité je pense c'est bon
incontestablement une diverge nous avons
très clairement une divergence et je
pense que ce que vous proposez
est une trahison ce qui est l'esprit
français et la République je crois que
c'est au contraire la défense la
République il y a une deuxième chose
parce que vous avez dit il y a le combat
contre l'islamisme faut pas confondre
les deux on a des millions de nos
compatriotes dans la religion est
l'Islam j'ai dit au début de mon propos
mais ils veulent vivre très
tranquillement je l'ai dit ils veulent
pouvoir latify ben laten par exemple qui
a perdu son fils
tomber sous un acte terroriste que nous
voyons tous avec émotion avec son son
foulard vous voulez lui arracher son
foulard
Madame Le Pen c'est ça ce que vous
proposez de manière très concrète donc
ce que je dis juste c'est que vous êtes
en train de pousser des millions de nos
compatriotes de par leur religion hors
de l'espace public la deuxième chose
l'islamisme qui n'est pas l'islam
l'islamisme je l'ai combattu comme aucun
président avant moi et aucun
gouvernement autorité auparavant par une
loi que vous n'avez pas voté elle non
plus d'autres que votre sensibilité on
le courage de la voter pour la
réaffirmation des principes de la
République elle a permis de faire quoi
ce qu'on ne pouvait pas faire jusque là
rien monsieur
je vous en prie ne dites pas de bêtises
associations qui ne respectaient pas la
loi de la République les unes parce
qu'elles prenait justement la charia la
non-égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes la sortie de la République les
autres parce qu'elle prenait un
nationalisme étranger sur notre console
d'autres encore parce qu'elles étaient
d'extrême droite et qu'elles ne
proposait de ne pas respecter la
République donc on a fermé des
associations on les a dissoutes la
deuxième chose vous avez encore donné
des chiffres exorbitants pour faire peur
aux gens sur 10.600 lieux de culte
vivement il y en a 99 qui étaient
suspectés de justement de séparatisme
tous ont été mis sous surveillance nos
préfets et nos services font un travail
extraordinaire je le dis ici avec
beaucoup de reconnaissance 23 ont été
fermés Grâce à cette loi 23 36 ont
changé et sont sous contrôle toutes les
autres sont en cours d'examen avant
cette loi on ne pouvait pas fermer une
telle structure même si vous aviez un
imam qui disait les pires choses on ne
pouvait les fermer qu'avec des critères
sanitaires la loi permet de le faire
cette loi a permis de mettre fin à un
système ou des gens qui étaient payés
par des puissances étrangères pour
enseigner sur notre sol
pouvez le faire en langue étrangère sans
sans le contrôle de l'éducation
nationale nous avons mis fin un système
on peut être technique on les appelait
celui des Alco
donc nous avons avancé mais en nous
battant contre l'islamisme radical celui
qui sépare de la République mais en
ayant mais en nous confondons pas
l'islam et l'islamisme radical vous avez
3 minutes pour répondre ce que viennent
exactement le sens de ma loi et encore
une fois merci d'ailleurs de me
permettre de rappeler à aux musulmans
que je ne m'aime pas de guerre contre
leur religion en aucun cas
dans un certain nombre de cas par
ailleurs
ils sont eux-mêmes des victimes des
islamistes en réalité qui subissent dans
leur quartier parce que les caïdes qui
s'organisent à un certain nombre de
quartiers sont bien souvent tenus par
les islamistes et ils sont toujours là
et ces quartiers sont toujours là et des
gens en souffrent encore et moi je
considère que c'est au contraire
défendre la République défendre
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
défendre la la ainsi que de s'opposer à
ces islamistes par l'intermédiaire d'une
loi qui les vise et qui ne vise que au
moins les choses seront extrêmement
claires
[Musique]